qu'en dit le cinéma c'est la vie oui
d'accord mais la vie c'est pas le cinéma
n'ont par exemple jamais dans la vraie
vie tu dis un mec je reviens j'ai enfilé
quelque chose et plus confortables et
bien évidemment sinon vestiaires surtout
que moi le truc confortable que j'ai
c'est pas une muse est en soi un toit
c'est un babygro et jamais dans la vraie
vie un mec il propose de monter boire un
dernier drink 6e
voici tout le temps dans médi spas drink
ses actes je dire parce que sinon oui
c'est sans arrêt quoi son chien mon père
a donnée vers 20 heures
ouais c'est bon ça va partir mais jamais
dans la vraie vie et mature elle démarre
sans clé ben évidemment ti et ben si
maintenant oui on peut re mue parce
qu'il ya des ya plutôt une clé était à
des capteurs dans la poche
ah oui mais non mais toi tu peux pas
savoir c'est parce que tu as un
chauffeur c'est pour çà a non monsieur
pas de chauffeur pour moi je me déplace
toujours un licorne qui sera jamais dans
la vraie vie que tu veux impressionner
quelqu'un tu arrives au ralenti
ça marche pas de l'or il faut quoi
talence et les lunettes et jamais dans
la vraie vie tu peux dire à un taxi
sujet cette voiture non non surtout si
ces jo qui va pas partout du coup il
doit pas suivre cette voiture qu'est ce
qu'il va voir damas est comprise et que
tu lui dis ah les issues de ses valises
et bien non parce que la beauté ouais
j'sais pas partout où je veux pas les
larmes excusez moi mais c'est dommage
parce que son saxo jaune connaît toutes
les routes par coeur tous les petits
bars tous les cons loi et la scène et
ses bougies noires c'est quand même con
qui avait pas partout et jamais dans la
vraie vie tu peux entendre sa propre
voix off commenté tes gestes 1 serait
bien tu imagines je me suis passé la
main dans les cheveux et là j'ai pensé
que la vie était vraiment recorte je
parle pas comme ça si tu vois ce que tu
t'entends pas rater et on tombe
l'intérieur
j'ai envie l'a giflée et je suis sûr
tenu vois que tu parles comme ça
et jamais dans la vraie vie tu peux
faire un flashback de 20 ans en arrière
pour voir comment tu étais
je vous
souvent c'est tant mieux jamais dans la
vraie vie tu as vanessa paradis qui
rigole avec toi sur un canapé banon par
contre on peut lui dire vas-y jo labazée
défense dans la nuit amazon vanessa
ok ça ni fleuve yalu